and finally new rule in 2018 it's more
important than ever that we all keep
laughing the nothing is funny people are
trying to take over the world and we
can't let them which is why I recently
posted this picture of me pulling an Al
Franken on a sleeping Bob Saget
it's a joke a joke about another joke so
I'm just saying here at the beginning of
the year if something like this is too
rough for you don't watch
now I'm also going to admit something
right here upfront that may influence
what I'm about to say tonight I have a
penis and while I admit that having one
does predispose a human to being
aggressive and oversexed I don't concede
that it makes me automatically wrong
about everything and I say that as a
true supporter of the me2 movement I
even wore black during the Golden Globes
I was home watching TV but still I wore
black but I was also mourning the
ability to think rationally I'm down
with me too I'm not down with me car
theism something is way off when senator
Kirsten Gillibrand can go unchallenged
saying when we start having to talk
about the differences between sexual
harassment and sexual assault and
unwanted groping you are having the
wrong conversation can't we just be
having an additional conversation
can we only have one thought now I get
it that Al Franken had to become
roadkill on the zero tolerance highway a
highway it seems only Democrats have to
drive on but what do liberals really
want to become the distinction deniers
the people who can't tell or don't want
to see a difference between a salt and a
van and a backrub by the water cooler
masturbation is normal and healthy but
not in the park giving up on the idea
that even bad things have degrees that
is as dumb as embracing the idea of
alternative facts
I get it when Trump side doesn't want to
talk he only knows 88 words but we are
supposed to be the conversation people
justice requires weighing things that's
why Lady Justice is holding a scale and
not a sawed-off shotgun
senator Gillibrand went on to say you
need to draw a line in the sand and say
none of it is okay yes agreed but we
can't walk and chew gum anymore we can't
agree that groping and rape are both
unacceptable and one is worse
apparently not because when Matt Damon
said there's a difference between
patting someone on the butt and rape or
child molestation right liberal Twitter
responded no there isn't Jason Bourne
yesterday you think he ate a lot of [ __ ]
in the Martian
[Applause]
many driver responded by saying you
don't get to tell women that because
some guy only showed them their penis
their pain isn't as great as a woman who
was raped what this is madness
no woman in the world that she actually
had to pick would choose rape over
merely seeing a penis so why do we all
have to pretend many drivers statement
is noble and Matt Damon is crazy we are
losing the thread back to thinking
itself you know the Declaration of
Independence starts with the words we
hold these truths to be self-evident
self-evident as in some things are such
obvious indisputable no-brainers that we
start from that point assuming role
generally on the page that [ __ ] is
measurably chemically different than
shinola
[Applause]
[Music]
but it seems that now building blocks
basic building blocks of thought like
there are facts and things have degrees
are being tossed aside Mike Pence and
Isis are both homophobic but Mike
doesn't throw gay men off the roof so
he's better this isn't that hard people
this isn't that hard I know we could do
it because we do it with other stuff
every millennial I know thinks it's
ridiculous that the government lists
marijuana as a schedule 1 drug along
with LSD and heroin because it is
ridiculous because things have degrees
there are 4 degrees of murder three
degrees of burns six degrees of Kevin
Bacon